one of the great things about the
bitcoin network is that on-chain
analytics allows us to see the flow of
funds that includes having identified
all of the wallets for the large
exchanges we can see how much are going
on to exchanges and how much bitcoin is
being taken off of the exchanges
watching to see when bitcoin comes off
exchanges is really important that means
the market's getting more illiquid you
can't just sit there and press a button
on an exchange and sell bitcoin if the
bitcoin's not there and it's been taken
off into cold storage and so watching
this metric is a key component of
understanding where price may go moving
forward well if we go ahead and we take
a look for the first time in a couple of
months binance one of the world's
largest exchanges is now showing that
bitcoin is coming off there's net
outflows on binance why is binance
specifically so important well if we go
ahead and we take a look at the charts
what we can see is that the overall
exchange balances of bitcoin has been
coming down since september of last year
but binance had actually been increasing
so binance was bucking the trend they
were going up in their bitcoin on the
exchange while all other exchanges were
coming down if we then go ahead and we
take a look now binance is having net
outflows as well and so if we go ahead
and we take a look we can see that on
all exchanges the bitcoin balance is
drastically coming down including on
binance you can see it right there
circled at the bottom right of this
chart and so now that we have binance
outflows then we can go ahead and
extrapolate this out what is going on on
the macro basis of all exchanges you can
see here with this orange line that the
balance on exchanges has been coming
down since about the end of 2019
actually and that coincides with a
massive run-up in price if we then go
ahead and we zoom in on january of 2020
what we can see is that january 2020
until now balances on exchanges is just
an absolute freefall this shows that the
bitcoin market is becoming more illiquid
it's becoming much easier for new demand
to push the price up and what we've seen
over that time period is that bitcoin
went from about 8 000 or so all the way
up to 69 000 today sits around 40 000
and so then if we can see over time the
inflows and outflows of these exchange
balances you can see that it hasn't
always been pure net outflows in the
green you see there are times of inflows
but right now over the last couple of
months since about the beginning of 2022
pretty much everyone is taking bitcoin
off of exchanges they're not putting it
on that is usually a sign that in the
future bitcoin's price will increase you
have an illiquid market you have
increasing demand price has to move to
accommodate everyone there is no way to
actually predict the future but on chain
metrics show you what's already
occurring and it's a great signal of
what could be to come continue to pay
attention to this exact metric of the
balances for exchanges because what it's
likely to show how illiquid the market
is and that is one of the key components
to understanding future bitcoin price
movements hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time